[Music]
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
okay what a lad well it's not every day
you get an olympic gold medalist on the
podcast or a two-time america's cup
winner but today i'm lucky enough to be
joined by a lad who has done both he's
also responsible for the new zealand
sporting moment of the decade after his
olympic gold medal race which inspired
the nation and going by the amount of
requests i've had to get him on the
podcast he is an absolute lad it is of
course the man himself joseph sullivan
welcome mate cheers mate
what an intro
matt great to have you on uh so what are
you up to at the moment uh just settling
into life down in todonga um back in the
fire service and yeah just getting used
to
um i don't know just family life again
it was quite good so how long have you
been down there uh we moved down just
after the
the end of the cup so around may
was living with the in-laws for a while
and then
finally found ourselves a place where we
we build up in welcome bay so
it's
all a new challenge all the different
kind of style go from being busy in the
americas captain being busy doing other
stuff so yeah
so talk to me about how that works like
so you're you're in team new zealand uh
you've just won
won the america's cup and then you're
what finished finished work have you
yeah so
yeah it's kind of it's a strange kind of
concept but you go from working
six seven days a week for nearly two
years
um to your pinnacle event which is the
cup and then you
you succeed which is fantastic and then
you go through the book party and
have a great time and then it's kind of
yeah it's the end and it's it's pretty
abrupt but it's it's not like we didn't
know it's kind of that way and
and i guess with covert in that we
didn't get to have the celebrations
around new zealand that
um we probably normally would have had
um but yeah challenging times for
everyone so
yeah we're just gonna take it as it
comes mate that's crazy so you're you're
contracted for like a two year period
are you and you're working as hard as
you can for that time and then you're
done yeah yeah it's yeah it's it's sport
i guess and it's that kind of game and
um with the america's covers as much as
the budget's massive it's not
so much for the the people it's more for
getting the boat on the water and the
development and and all the structure in
the boat and
yeah it all it all disappears and dries
up pretty quickly and
yeah as much as the team would love to
keep funding everyone they it just can't
be done so
yeah yeah so to go again you have to how
does it work for the next america's cup
um yeah i guess we retrial and and go
through that process again um
grinders aren't really needed throughout
the year so
we just kind of go back into our own
little
world and keep fit and try to keep on
targets and
yeah
and put our best foot forward when the
day comes if we get asked again mate
that's crazy so how does how does the
troll work for a grinder is it literally
go grind as hard as you can or is it is
there a technique to it uh there wasn't
much technique at the end of the day
raw mongrel really
you just pretty much thrashing yourself
to put out the best numbers you can yeah
and we put you through a series of
different tests from sprints to
endurance and
and some of us are better at some things
and some of us yeah
we're all kind of
um i guess we complement each other in
different ways throughout the team so
some guys are a mess of sprinters but
and some of us are way better at
endurance so
yeah i think having that range of of
strengths in the team is is really
important and are you an endurance man
from your rowing background
yeah i'd love to say as a sprinter and
i've done a few sprints in my time but
now the the power that some of those
boys can put out is just impressive and
i don't even have a [ __ ] show of keeping
up with them so
yeah endurance is more my forte i'll
start and finish it at the same kind of
pace that i
i set off at so right if it's anything
like you're rowing you're finishing
stronger than your start
yeah it's true i try to yeah
finish in the world of hurt yeah [ __ ]
mate that's that's interesting so then
when's the next um america's cup when
when's your next sort of trial to go for
are you gonna put your name forward
again yeah definitely put my name for it
again it's it's a pretty cool experience
and
um to go for the three people would be
pretty special
but at the end of the day i know it's
sport and always looking for the best
new talent and
i'd be stupid to think that i've got a
seat sewn up um so yeah
i'll start training again
soon
um
and try not to get fat like i have a few
times
just
yeah be ready for it if it if it comes
and if it doesn't kind of
yeah it's it's sported at the end of the
day so do you get any benefit from
having experience as a grinder i i guess
just understanding what's happening on
the boat
um and the different demands that are on
you
and then being able to deal with the
pressure um during a race and throughout
the race and before the race even
um and not psych yourself out or train
too hard or just
you kind of need to have a fine
balancing act yeah as you do in most
sports um to be able to perform on that
day
and not pretty much not [ __ ] it up
really
[Laughter]
well you obviously didn't do that
because you guys had a very successful
campaign didn't you yeah well there were
definitely some challenging days where
we
we thought we were gonna go two-nil and
um we went one all and and things like
that so
it's also being able to deal with that
kind of
um disappointment and just being able to
keep keep going and keep fighting right
till the end yeah never given up because
you obviously don't come from a sailing
background either do you so did you
learn all this pretty quickly
uh
yeah pretty quickly so i i did say i was
a kid i was made to jump in a sunburst
with my brother because he was a
passionate sailor
and i hated it like
sailing was not my thing
i was a little i think i was eight when
i started and kind of finished when i
was 12. yeah and then moved up to picton
and got told by the head boy that i was
going to start rowing so
yeah true it's kind of weird that kicked
off what do you mean you got told you're
going to start right by the head boy
did he literally just come up and tell
you yeah so i moved moved towns and
moved up from rangiora to picton
um went to the local college and pretty
much at the start of the year they do
their cross country
i started as a little 13 year old and
managed to
to win the cross country here he is and
literally
at the time
ryan gordon
um just came up to me and he was like
you're going to start rowing how's that
oh yeah sweet
didn't have anything else to do and
yeah
why not give it a go did you like it did
you enjoy it yeah loved it um
good bunch of leads lots of banter
um yeah it was just good fun i remember
turning up for the first day of rowing
and the
the coach at the time pulled up in his
little hilux
um
dear peg on the back he was an evid
hunter
i'm straight from the freezing works and
you he pulled up and wound the window
down he's are you here for the rowing
and i was like yeah you're real keen and
he's like well you'll be no good you're
too [ __ ] small
you drove off and parked a shoe you know
i was like oh cool
this is gonna be fun
well it's very close yeah so you were
short for aurora were you yeah well i
still am um i think at the olympics i
was the shortest and lightest wow
heavyweight true yeah obviously didn't
restrict you though hey
nah i just had to change our style but
we're we're more like a jack russell
racing a labrador
taking heaps more steps
so what's what was your training like
because i remember a couple of rowers at
uh my school at the time they used to
have to get up real early in the morning
train pretty hard and then head off to
school is it similar for you
uh probably not so much through my
school we had to um
we'd a little um mitsubishi van that we
had to drive through from picton through
to blenheim yeah and then we had some
sheds that we put in the
or so the blenheim roaring club was up
on stilts pretty much near the river
and then we slipped some tin up in the
stilts and we used to put our boats
underneath this shed
so we could only really train in the
afternoons
so we just kind of finished school got
together in the van and then
kept it through to blenheim and
um
instead of we'd probably do like 20k to
30k a day
just in the afternoons as school kids
um
and then do the the one early morning on
a saturday but
it was never really that early it was
around seven
so yeah we had probably a crazy
lifestyle but when we did train we had a
good bunch of lads and they just loved
to
push it as hard as they could at every
moment did did you know that you were
good like from a young
age uh
not really i just kind of
was part of the crew
um was just having fun i think in our
first year
we didn't even make an a final i think
we got second in a b final and we're
pretty stoked with that
um
but then again we i guess we we wanted
to win and we were pretty keen so
we started training even harder and then
the next year
picked up i think two gold medals and
that kind of just set it off caught the
bag yeah i guess we got a feel of it
after that that we were we had potential
we definitely weren't the prettiest we
were
our technique was terrible but we just
kind of trained harder than everyone
else and
we were just fit where did you learn
your technique because obviously
you had to learn your
good technique from somewhere when did
you start picking up on the techniques
side of things um i guess it just comes
i guess it comes a bit natural
um and then once you get kind of got
into the new zealand teams and stuff and
they start to focus on it a bit more but
yeah
i don't think i've ever had the best
technique in rowing and you can probably
ask a lot of people mine's always been
terrible but
i've always just made it work for me
my style is very different to everyone
else's
and definitely when i got together with
nathan that was a
big thing that we had to overcome um
kind of matching our styles up together
so you started off as a single sculler
but then you changed the double so was
that what was the reason behind that
transition
well
i went to four new zealand during the
trials
i won
probably 11 gold medals at new zealand
secondary schools wow and from all those
trials i got selected into the team not
once
they always told me i was too short not
compatible
and it kind of wasn't until i got taken
to an onboardsman
by the mobile rowing association
that i actually got a forced entry into
the new zealand journey team
so i actually started in a double with
one of my
school mates daniel karina
and we went to world juniors and we
ended up getting uh a third with only
eight weeks training
and the the teams that they selected all
got second and b finals or were not even
in them crazy
that was pretty special right that's mad
yeah
and then from there when i went into the
single i was actually the reserve
for the men's four
so i i didn't get sent in the single as
the single sculler i got sent as the
reserve and then ended up winning the
first um under 23 worlds
geez so does height does hype make that
much of a difference so that they were
just even though you're winning all
these races you weren't they weren't
gonna pick you i think
like
the new zealand team was so focused on
the glory of the eights back in back in
the day yeah and all those guys were
just big guys
and that's kind of what they saw as
rowers like they looked for people that
were well over six foot they had long
legs long arms and that was kind of
their ultimate the selectors were the
guys from back in the day
so they were looking for the guys of
their own image i guess
um
and i just didn't fit that
i was
i was short arms long back i'm exactly
what a rubber should not be
i'm literally the complete opposite of
what a road should be
mate but that's so cool doing it for the
little men or the the short-armed men
yeah so cool so you must your mindset
must just be next level the way that you
can push yourself and compete with these
guys who are
i guess have the physical attributes of
a rower i guess i'm just stubborn yeah
like i was always like my siblings were
all a bit older than me
i hated being left out and i think that
was just pretty much it every time i got
told i couldn't do anything other than
that back then i'm gonna give it a go i
like to prove a point i guess
um and it just couldn't work for me you
certainly proved your point so you
talked about your nathan's relationship
um and how you had to adjust so what
what was that relationship like
initially um it was pretty good though
we got along and we'd always raced each
other throughout school um nathan always
kicked my ass in the single
but i was luckily a few years
after him so
he kind of went and dominated the single
and then i came through the next few
years after and and dominated the single
at secondary schools
um so we always had competed against
each other like james hargis and queen
charlotte college back in the day i
always had a kind of
a massive rivalry
but we all got along at the same time
which was really cool
um
so then when we eventually got into the
double together
um yeah i was just trying to emulate him
and get into his style but i just
couldn't match it
he had really long arms and i just had
really short arms
and i guess we just had to figure that
out
um
and adapt our style because yeah it was
impossible to make one of us
row like the other so then we had to
just find that medium ground
um but i guess it ended up complementing
each other
like i kind of go better to hell from
the start and then he's really strong
through the middle of the race and then
i just got a bit nuts at the end
we
managed to make it work
so you have to keep your own the same
tempo the whole race obviously and how
important is that uh yeah it's pretty
pretty important like i guess
like ultimately in a race you would want
to keep the same tempo right from the
start to the finish but
i've never been able to do that i kind
of start and then find into a rhythm and
then try to hold that as best i can and
then
i get to a point in the race where i
know i can finish it off and just kind
of
go for it but
yeah mostly in rowing it is finding that
pace throughout the race and then
holding it and then trying to get better
at the end yeah
um but i've always known my the middle
of my wrist has always been pretty
average
um and it's always something i've been
trying to work on but
yeah that's where nathan was really
really strong which was cool to be
paired up with him
and and when you talk about that last
500 meters is that can technique go out
the window or like how important
technique still in these moments when
you when you are just emptying the tank
that's definitely important because if
you're not getting the blade in the
water at the right spot you're just
wasting energy but yeah um
yeah we we just kind of got into a
rhythm that we knew
no matter how many 500s we did
no matter how screwed we were we could
always kind of do a time
right at the end of the race
so no matter how buggered we were
if we got to that last 1500 metres we
knew
we could just finish so
yeah um
yeah it was almost because
at that point you just want to kill over
you
you're hurting you're struggling and you
just want it to end
but you know that you've just got to
keep doing that next stroke and that
neck stroke and then extra right to the
finish
um
and
i kind of remember looking back at the
race for the first time
and all i could see was my head going
side to side and i
remember trying to think what i was
thinking at the time and i was just
looking for the finish line because i
just wanted it to be over yeah and
everyone's like did you know you won and
if you look at the video
no i had no idea i thought we got third
three was this in the uh the london
olympic one the final yeah the london
olympics i thought we got three oh did
you
i didn't even notice that we passed
everyone oh wow
you weren't hurt locker yeah that was
until we kind of looked up at the big
screen
oh let's crack up and that's one of the
greatest races obviously in new
zealand's sporting history
talk to me about the whole um build up
to that race and the lead up to that
event
um our buildup was pretty poor eh
we kind of
we had this massive training block in
new zealand and um we kind of went into
it knowing that we were going to be
in the hurt locker before we got on the
plane to go to europe for the world cups
and and things like that yeah and we
went through all that
and i remembered like a few days before
we got on the plane to leave to europe
the selectors pulled us aside and were
like what are you guys up to well what
do you mean and they're like well you
you're going like [ __ ]
like you probably shouldn't even be
going
and we're like [ __ ]
like what the hell this is not what we
want to hear just before we get on the
plane
overseas
and um
so we kind of take that on board and
we're a bit
we don't know what to do because
i guess when you put yourself in that
that position and you
you've been training so hard and you you
make yourself hurting you're also
mentally fatigued and physically
fatigued so
when someone comes and says that to you
you just you take it all the wrong way
yeah um
and we went into our first world cup
that weekend like you go straight into
it once you get to europe
and we went
absolute balls we like
we got second to last in the b final
right because it it just
and it mentally ruined us having the
selectors come to us and just tell us we
were wrong like [ __ ] yeah
and then all of a sudden me and nathan
were trying to figure out like why we're
running like [ __ ] and we
we kind of just instead of sticking to
what we knew and what we were doing
we just went the complete opposite and
started going real terribly
um
so so that was a bit terrifying we get
second to last we're only just beating
like iran and countries that are just
not there for rowing yeah
we're freaking out a bit and then
it's quite tense between the two of us
for a few months
and we're just trying to figure out what
we're going wrong and when we start
doing all the kind of wrong things we're
looking
we start changing little things that we
didn't even need to look at
and
training was hard and we were pretty
grumpy with each other and the worse we
were going the harder we tried to train
so we were just staying in that mental
fatigue yeah longer and longer and
longer
and it wasn't until
i don't know quite late into it it was
the third world cup before the olympics
and we kind of
we were like what the hell are we doing
we need to just go back to basics and we
we kind of set ourselves up again
and um
yeah we just went straight back to
basics doing the real simple things
again that we'd always done
and kind of threw out the window of all
these changes that we'd made and we we
put all our settings and our boat back
to what we had originally in new zealand
yeah when we were happy with it and we
were going well
and then all of a sudden we kind of
clicked again
um
and we ended up getting uh silver at the
world cup just before the olympics yeah
and we're like okay
we do have something here so what
inspired those little changes to um that
you made uh i think we were just looking
for things that weren't even there so i
think our coach started coming up with
different ideas of what it could be and
yeah
it just wasn't there and we just started
going down the wrong path yeah
and i think leading into the olympics we
were in belgium for like six weeks
before we went to london
and it rained every day
and we were just
we were just in a bad space i think yeah
um
i think it was like there was a few days
where me and nathan didn't even talk to
each other
and we were living in the same room
biking to training together and rowing
in the same boat and we just didn't talk
and it was
it was tense and it was i guess it was
like looking back it was just stupid but
when you're in that fatigue and you're
in that zone yeah like everything's just
real niggly
and things that shouldn't get to you
just get to you and
um luckily we kind of
i don't even know what set it off but we
kind of had an argument one day and then
we just kind of cleared the air yeah and
we kind of just
like what the [ __ ] are we doing we need
to sort this out yeah and we
we actually agreed to to go on a road
trip together and we
ended up talking to our coach who wasn't
happy about it and we talked to our
manager who wasn't really happy about it
either but he
kind of agreed with us that we needed to
get away and we were in this place that
called micklin in belgium and
um
we told our coaches that we're going to
go to bruges and bruce's about an hour's
drive from where we were yeah but
instead we we rented a car and started
driving to the south of france which was
twelve thousand
twelve hundred k's away
and we left it like
we left at five at night on a friday and
we we thought we'd drive halfway find a
hotel and then came there for the night
and then did the rest of the trip yeah
started our trip and the motorway was
real busy and we were like what the hell
found out there was the first day of
summer holidays over in belgium
and we were literally traveling with
thousands of other people
through the middle of the night we
couldn't find accommodation anywhere and
then we ended up
like in the south of france and
marseille
we just took turns driving through the
night
and
we got to this mcdonald's and it was
back in the day when you didn't have
data on your phone yeah so we had to
find a mcdonald's so then we could get
wi-fi and we just searched like
the best beach in marseille
and then we literally drove to this
little beach
and it was just the best time we
we had some sunshine for the first time
in months and yeah we just cruised to
the beach went swimming got a little
yacht went sailing
we took our bikes with us and went bike
riding and
literally all we needed was this mental
break
um
and it was just it was epic it was just
a good time
had a few beers had some pizza and just
uh i guess we just connected his mates
again instead of just getting niggly at
each other yeah
that's living and then the next day we
packed up and drove all the way back to
belgium
and then
talking to people they're like where
have you guys been and we're like oh we
went to the south of france and they're
like [ __ ] off you did like no one
no one believed us we're completely
telling the truth and everyone's like no
whatever but what a joke and
just looking back at things like that
now i i honestly think if we didn't do
that one trip away yeah we we wouldn't
have got a medal at the olympics um
after that one trip and just that mental
break
and getting that bit of mental health
back and that
we just revived really yeah like we were
still tired and we were still knackered
but
just having that change of pace and that
change of scenery
we
we came back firing and that whole build
up for the next two weeks
leading into london like we were
unstoppable when it just gave us
so much confidence and and
realization that we actually had a shot
at
it maybe get in the middle so
yeah crazy so when you say that you're
trying like you're not getting a break
how intense is that training leading up
to that like you obviously can't have a
pizza or a few beers
most nights
well you can definitely have a pizza and
a few beers we're just burning calories
but
i think just being in that lockdown
where you're in it
in the training camp and i guess lots of
sports will understand this like you go
overseas and you're so focused on that
one event
and then
if you're having a few bad days then you
try to train
the bad things out so
we ended up but we were getting worse so
instead of
pulling back and giving ourselves a
break we started pushing harder yeah so
we went from training six days a week to
seven days a week
and instead of like having a break we
were just making ourselves worse and
worse and worse
and literally just just stepping back
for two days
was enough and that
kind of just gave us the peace of mind
and the confidence and and that
connection as a crew again
um
yeah
to just do the basics well that we'd
always done right how cool is that so
then you were feeling pretty confident
heading into the olympics after that
two-week two-day uh two-day tour
yeah
yeah our whole build-up had been
terrible and then two weeks before the
olympics we just had a really good
moment and
and found the speed that we used to have
and that that feel that we used to have
as well yeah because in rowing um it's
literally about feel like yeah
you can row a boat as hard as you want
but if it doesn't feel good and it
doesn't move the way you want it to
you're just wasting energy so
yeah it's real
it's yeah it's sounds like it's easy to
do but it's real hard to find that
rhythm as a as a combination right it
doesn't sound easy at all so then what
about your arm qualifying did you feel
confident heading into those qualifiers
um
you're never really confident like
you have a sense that you can achieve
and and
like it wasn't like we were the worst
rollers in the world we were the world
champions currently and we had defended
that twice before getting to the
olympics yeah but it was kind of funny
like our build-up was so terrible that
it everyone had written us off like the
media weren't even following us
which was perfect yeah in the hindsight
like
we didn't have that pressure that
probably eric and bondy had or maher had
or emma had
we were kind of going into it as all
these boys are going like [ __ ] don't
expect much from them so
it was it was almost perfect for us um
but yeah for me going into the olympics
it's
it's the same as world champs you're
racing the same people but
it's one of those events that everyone
can put their best foot forward at the
end of the day and you never know
who's going to be on fire
um in those heats and in those semis so
for me it was quite nerve-wracking and
having the massive crowds you go from
having like
5 000 people at a world champs watching
to
i think there was 60 or 70 000 people
watching on the grandstands in london
and you can hear them from the start
line and i remember race like
doing a warm-up session going to the
start of the heat
it was just the heat and we were racing
crews that we knew we could smash but
i was so nervous that i ended up like
vomiting
in the boat
going to the start line and i've never
done that before ever in my life like
i've been to world champs six times and
i've been to everything and
just having that nerves that
everyone at home is watching like no one
really watches a world champs until the
final but yeah at the olympics
everyone's watching the heaps they're
watching the semis they're watching the
repertoire it's like
that expectation and that i guess got to
me but
as soon as i vomited and as soon as i
let it out
i was i was calm again
just
yeah good to go and you get that one
race under your belt and everything just
starts feeling way better
and you get that confidence again so
so what were the nerves like for the big
final to be fair
for the final i was far more calm than i
was even going into the heat the heat
was more nerve-wracking to me
than the final um
winning the heat and then getting that
confidence then going into the semis
and and knowing that we still had a bit
more power to come how did you know that
just because you're feeling good yeah i
guess um just leading into it we we kind
of went through that race and um
we kind of let
one of the crews get in front of us a
bit and then we just pushed up to them
when we could hold them
and we kind of just knew that we didn't
have to
exert everything that we had to get to
that final yeah and that was a really
good feeling um
knowing that we were slightly holding
back
ready for the the big race and even
leading into london were like we knew
the lanes were slightly um
i guess biased there was always a slight
side wind from one side of the course to
the other so
if you were if you won then you got
stuck right in the middle
um but if we didn't win we got stuck
slightly to the side so
we almost did a slight gamble and we we
ended up in the perfect lane for the
race and did you and your plan for that
race was it always to
start off relatively slow and finish
strong or was that just is that just
what happened
no that's that's absolutely never our
plan
um it always looks like it is because it
happens to us every time but every time
we race we try to get out with everyone
else and we try to hold in the main
group
and then
give it a good push at the end but
every race we do we kind of got known
for our sprint finishes
um from the world champs in 2010 yeah so
crews knew
that they had to get on top of us and
try hold us off
um
so yeah we went into that last final
knowing that everyone was going to try
gap it from us
and we just couldn't keep up literally
um we had a really good start and i
thought everything was going really well
and nathan was giving me
real good feedback
i don't look out of the boat and he
makes all the calls so
going down through the 750s like yep
we're right in it keep going keep going
we're going good we're going good
through the thousand you keep like
telling me we're going good we're right
up in the in the where we need to be
we're going good
1500 we're going good and then
um
just yeah the last 500 he's just like
yep go and we just kind of went we don't
even say anything for that last 500
meters but
looking back at the race now i 100 know
he was lying to me the whole way
[Laughter]
we were we were well off the page
we were four seconds behind at the
thousand meter mark like um yeah
yeah what's he told you since the race
was he always confident or not yeah i
think nathan always knew we had like we
had that potential and he knew other
crews had kept it from us but
i guess if you're looking after
yourselves as a crew you're not going to
tell your mate that you you're going
really bad you're just going to keep
them positive and that's what he did
yeah which is real
really cool and it's having that trust
in your crew that
we're going to back each other up but
i just have to believe what he's saying
and i don't look out of the boat i try
to stay focused on uh rhythm and
and keep driving forward and
he makes the calls so
i trusted him and he he did it perfectly
he lied to me when he needed to and
he got us to the
to the 1500 meter mark where we needed
to be and then yeah we kind of just
unleashed it together and
and just yeah let all the mongrel out
and let it all out and got to the line
for a third in your mind
yeah yeah
yeah and it's amazing how happy you can
be with a third
like
getting a bronze at the olympics was
like to me i was ecstatic that was
incredible yeah and then to look up at
the screen like to to see the screen and
then realize that we'd actually won was
just i was beside myself
that's so cool and what's the
celebrations like what's the how does
aurora celebrate our olympic gold medal
um you'd actually be super disappointed
with us
with our
celebrations the night of our medal
you go from doing the hardest race of
your life into literally we did seven
hours of media
interviews oh true like you finish the
race you rode to the dice
you do a circuit with the media you
don't even get to warm down or anything
like that
um
you get your medal and then you go to a
conference and um
you have to sit there and chat about the
race and then from there you go and talk
to more media yeah and then you get like
20 minutes to see your family and have a
drink
and the beer or the alcohol just goes
straight to your head
[Laughter]
and then you get put in another car and
driven off to go talk to some more media
yeah
and then by the end of it like all i
wanted to do was just go home yeah
we literally just went back to the hotel
and
then got a bed and went to bed um i was
naked
yeah and
it's so surreal like
for me
like the olympics have been 12 years of
my life
to get that one achievement and
then to have it in your hand
and it was there it almost didn't make
sense it was yeah it was almost surreal
um but even taking that night
just to kind of chill on my own and and
realize what had happened
was pretty cool
and then after that it all kind of let
loose
it was it was good
but yeah
i think the best thing about the
olympics for aurora as it's normally
done in the first five days
so you get another
eight to ten days of just absolute
partying
yeah it was it was an experience like no
other i'd have to say that like an
olympic gold medal gets you into every
party and to every every sport that you
want to go watch that's so saying yeah
it's good fun did you party with any um
any famous names
um
not really we we went to a few bars that
i'd never even known existed
um
before in my life and
i guess there were famous people there
but we didn't really get to mingle with
them
i remember the one night that i didn't
go out
like the one out of all those nights
the boys came back and they were like we
were partying with ludacris
he was like yeah he was shutting us like
champagne with gold flakes in it all
night it was fantastic i was like son of
a [ __ ]
one night it didn't go out i missed out
on that um
yeah but it's always classic like that
but yeah i my mental state during that
was probably i can't remember half of
the putting we were like you go from
being the fittest you've ever been to
drinking every night and it's
it's pretty torturous on the body
and then what's the
what's the crash like when i guess when
you're getting back to reality you're
like you said you've been planning for
this for 12 years and it's it's all
happened and then
you're back to reality i guess yeah
that's
it's a strange it's a strange strange
thing eh like
and i can't imagine how the athletes are
feeling after tokyo like
you kind of have this pinnacle event
that you've been working your whole life
for
and then
you have all these big parties and
that's really cool and then you come
back and you have a few more big parties
and everything's sweet and then
a week after that like you you you're
pretty much old
like you're old news really um
and you're just back to life as normal
when it
it's it's a strange
strange place it
it's definitely a hard
kind of thing to comprehend
like you don't have that routine that
you had before like you would go to
training and you do this and you do that
all of a sudden that's gone you don't
need to go to training anymore
um
yeah so it was a different kind of
lifestyle
it was it was a strange kind of feeling
after that and i remember we had a
meeting with rowing new zealand and got
told we could have
four months off and i was like man
that's fantastic i don't think i've had
a break in the last kind of 12 years
um so i took that as eagerly as i could
and
i remember like a month after that my
coach was like oh you got to start
training you know the boys are going
real fast and i was just like
what the hell like
you've just been told you could have a
four month break and then all of a
sudden you're getting told you have to
come back because everyone's going real
quick yeah i made it it's like the year
after the olympics no one no one cares
let us enjoy it and
little little did i know that was pretty
much the end of my career
because you didn't go back or did you
want to finish
i i said i was going to have a break and
i kind of
took the next month or two so i ended up
only having a break for
two months i think
and just from there it was all kind of
over i i didn't get put in the same
boats that i should have been put in and
i got told i didn't deserve this and
yeah my career just kind of
disappeared out from under me it was a
strange strange time that's crazy so you
i always thought that you just finished
on your own terms but you were actually
just weren't selected
the current olympic champion took a
couple of months off and now he's not
good enough
yeah it was almost like
i got i got shunned pretty much it was a
strange
strange strange thing like
we got told that we didn't need to be
back on form and that they would build
crews around us and stuff like that to
just being literally axed and
and told that you were the reserve or
like
yeah you didn't deserve to be in this
crew and i'm like what this is so messed
up
um
yeah so definitely went through a
massive mental battle
through that kind of period of my life
um
and it kind of just
it kind of ruined my passion for the
sport and and getting told after winning
olympic gold medal after winning like
six world champs
that i had to be proving myself and and
jumping through these hoops again yeah
it just
absolutely messed with me and i
yeah i i definitely just lost the
passion for it and lost lost the drive
to be pushing hard
um
i kind of always told myself to win an
olympic gold medal for rowing
you need a good four-year build up and
and all of a sudden my first year of
those four years was destroyed and then
yeah my my passion for the second year
just got worse and
um all of a sudden they were putting
different guys in to the double and
and telling me i didn't even deserve a
shot at trialing for that seat was
yeah it was mentally
like yeah pretty much mentally [ __ ] me
really yeah um
and after that i was like nah screw it i
don't need the [ __ ]
which is really sad
um because i i knew i still had
potential and i i really wanted to back
it up
but just getting
getting made to jump through hoops again
was just insane so
yeah i ended up calling it quits and
right that's absolute madness
so how did you deal with it mentally
obviously it would have been incredibly
tough what what sort of got you through
that
um i don't think much got me through
that i was doing it pretty dark
it was a pretty dark space for quite a
long time i remember like when i finally
decided to end it with rowing
like i'd just be in bed
half the day i i just didn't have any
reason to get out i didn't know what i
was doing
i kind of thrown all my eggs in one
basket rowing was everything that i
was doing i
i hadn't really like i'd gone to
university but i wasn't really enjoying
that and it wasn't the path i wanted to
go down
um
so when i ended i didn't really have
anything to to drive myself for or look
towards
um
yeah and it was a weird situation
but i think one of the strangest things
that kind of happened was
i got asked to do an interview for a guy
called david slifield
um
and he was kind of looking for
i guess the x factors or or what makes a
good olympian and a medalist
and
like what kind of things that impacted
my life that made me
be like i was or being mentally
resilient
for
the olympics or for my sport
and um
just had some really good yarns with him
and then at the end of that he was kind
of like
i i do some work with team new zealand
and you'd be a really good fit
and i was like man that that'd have been
meant by
yeah i've never really thought about it
but being part of team new zealand would
be really cool and
this was literally just after team new
zealand had just had the biggest upset
in sporting history
um
losing
losing from eight points up to
just losing it yeah
so it was like the most devastating time
watching that well i've just been
dropped from the new zealand running
team to excited to watch at the americas
cup and getting up every morning to see
them lose day after day after being so
close to winning it yeah
and
like man that's just that's just strange
and then
um nothing kind of happened after that
and then i ended up
joining the new zealand fire service and
and getting involved in that and kind of
found a new passion with that yeah and
then randomly one day i just got a phone
call
from david again and he's like team new
zealander looking for grinders i'll put
your name down expect a call and i was
like
ah holy [ __ ]
this is awesome so
yeah the next day i get a call from um
glen ashby and he's like come down and
have a look and see what you think
and that was
kind of the start of a new career i'd
gone from
the bottom of the pits and then
all of a sudden i was
yeah back into it
far out what a journey so had you done
any grinding before or was this just
completely out of the blue just he just
basically picked you from your mental
toughness
yeah it was you know pretty much out of
the blue um
yeah it was kind of like the teams
having a massive rebuild lots of people
have left lots of people have stayed
um well like no lots of people left a
few people have stayed and
i think it's a really good time to get
involved in the team the team that's
there is really cool and
they're dedicated to it and they're just
passionate about what they're doing and
that just sounded like the dream
scenario for me
i remember who said like they've got no
money so don't expect anything
and to me it didn't really matter i just
like it was
i guess it was the challenge that i was
up for um
yeah and i was still working at the fire
service and then on my days off so you
do four days on four days off in the
fire service and yeah yeah my days off
i'd go out on the yacht and
and was learning to sell
and then test boat and learning to grind
and just doing jobs around the yard and
stuff like that and
yeah it kind of learned the dynamic of
team new zealand which is literally not
it's not always the most talented person
but it's always
the guy that's going to be passionate
about it and put his best foot forward
and work for that common goal and it was
just an awesome atmosphere to be part of
yeah what is that what is team new
zealand like who how does it all work
who runs the cutter
there's there's lots of different bosses
i guess throughout the whole team
um everyone likes to think they're in
charge i think
yeah i guess
like for the grinding team
we kind of do our training and then we
become
the
the dog's body of the team we do all the
jobs that no one wants to do
yeah um
we like get out in the yard in being
containers of
stuff that hasn't been touched since the
version fives and
and like gluing
gluing down little pad eyes that no one
wants to touch and yeah also
painting wall off the wall or moving
moving this thing to there and then no
no it doesn't really work then we'll
move that back over there
and we
were literally just the grunt men of the
team
um
but it was cool we did all the the jobs
the boat builders didn't have time to do
or or didn't need to waste their time
doing manual things
um
but it created a massive team atmosphere
um
where we did the the [ __ ] jobs for them
and then if we went out sailing and
ruined the boat then they would work all
night to make sure it was ready for us
the next day yeah and it was just a
wicked team atmosphere that's cool and
what's the grinders training like you
said that you guys would do training in
the morning what what's that involved
um
it was pretty similar to wrong in many
ways like
we would start a session and it could be
anywhere from an hour to two hours
um
just endurance or weights or or speed
work
and then
literally after that we go have
breakfast and then we're into the day
like helping out around the shed
and then
towards the afternoon we start kind of
tiring and and
getting worse at doing our jobs
peel back into the gym and push
ourselves again for the afternoon true
is it all upper body stuff
mainly
uh yeah a lot a lot of upper body it's
um
it's more full body than you think it
would be yeah like it's it's pretty
similar to say boxing where lots of the
power comes from the rotation and the
twist and and things like that so
yeah you do get bigger arms but your
body is also going to be pretty fit
to balance it out really and how does it
compare with the lungs compared to
rowing
uh
it definitely doesn't hurt the lungs as
much as rowing yeah because once your
arms are once your arms are buggered
there's there's not much you can do
about it
they
they just tend to jelly and you can be
as fit as you want to be but as soon as
your arms are gone there's nothing
there's just nothing you can do about it
like you could keep trying to push but
your arms just won't do it it's it's a
strange feeling like if you go and do a
bench press and try to do
as many like unlimited bench press yeah
you start off real good and your form's
really tight and then as you get like to
10 it gets worse and then as you get to
20 it gets worse
you get around 30 and you're just
walking around it's just
yeah there's absolutely nothing you can
do about it yeah so when you when you
are training a you are you emptying your
tank every session or is that what you
have to push yourself to or is it a bit
more technical than that no it
definitely was we always kind of
um the competitiveness between the team
was i guess what drove us to the levels
that we got to
like um
as much as i hated i hate i hate numbers
i hate reading my data i just like doing
the training and then and then going
home yeah but
yeah a lot of the team love the data and
love that comparison between each other
yeah and you can't help but get dragged
into it as much as i didn't enjoy it
so that numbers would always get put up
on the board and then it just gets
competitive and then you're always
trying to outdo each other and
you're trying to figure out ways that
you can slightly get better than the
other person yeah and you're always
pushing the limits yeah it's always yeah
it's good banter and what was it like
obviously the whole uh america's cup in
here in new zealand what what was that
like oh mate the the atmosphere for the
america's cup in new zealand is is
second to none
now we did that whole campaign in
bermuda and it was as cool as bermuda
was
there just wasn't the crowds and the
support that we get when we're in new
zealand and
like you
you're leading into like you go to work
every day and you go past all these
people and no one really notices you
and then all of a sudden you've got a
regetta on and all of a sudden there's
thousands of people
and they're all looking at you they're
checking to see if you're wearing the
same uniform as all the crew and
like all of a sudden you're an important
person
yeah and
like the whole feel of auckland and new
zealand just changes um
like the media starts getting behind us
instead of writing stories bagging us
out for being money hungry sports teams
and we're
we're pushing their limits and we're
getting special treatment and then all
of a sudden everyone's like oh team new
zealand are great we've always backed
them like
but
it's it's such a cool atmosphere and to
see the excitement from everyone around
new zealand just really helps
like pump you up and get you excited
about what you're doing
and
it makes you feel it is pretty special
to be part of the team
you kind of go through all those hard
days where you're like man this is just
draining and like why are we doing this
why are we doing this to ourselves and
then you kind of notice
everyone around you getting excited and
like knowing that people would give
anything to be in the position that
you're at kind of brings it back into
perspective that
um what you're doing is really cool
and i i i'd say like any top sports
person must feel like that
you have those just absolute slog days
where you question why you're doing your
sport while you're doing this to
yourself
but you're literally
little kids dreams like
you're doing exactly what they want to
do when they grow up or you're you're
fulfilling someone's dream lifestyle
and
you know it really makes you you sit
back and realize how special it is what
you're doing
and how great the opportunity is that
you've got to be part of that team and
and fighting for the america's cup
that's so true and did you feel like you
enjoyed the team bigger team environment
compared to the rowing or is it hard to
compare the two it's definitely it's a
strange comparison like in rowing you've
you've almost got to be pretty selfish
yeah
and look after number one or look after
your crew
because even within rowing new zealand
although you're a big team
like the competitive streak between like
say the men's double versus the men's
pair or
um
we're all trying to fight for that top
position
and you
you always race and do these um
these trainings throughout the week
where you get rated prognostically
against the world record
for each event
and
like we're all doing different times so
say emma's in the single of course the
men's double's going to kick her on time
yeah but even her handicap compared to
her world best time she can beat us at
the end of the day
in like a 4k race prognostically so
everyone's real competitive for that one
prognostic to try to be top of that
sheet
um
and
like as much as you you're old mates at
the end of the day you get like real
competitive and you get a bit sassy
against each other like you're always
trying to one-up each other and i guess
that's what makes the team so strong
is that even though we're all in
different boats in different categories
we're all fighting to be top of that
list and and that compared to america's
cup i guess
there's none of that is there you're all
you're all in it together well
definitely there with the grinding team
but
when you walk out into the shed and you
see like the 60 boat builders slogging
their asses off
um
working through the night and not seeing
their families for ages and then all the
office staff up there designing away and
having meeting after meeting about
development and you kind of realized
you're only a small cog in this massive
machine
that's all working for that common goal
and it kind of
uh it definitely puts it into
perspective that you you've just got to
do your best
and as as little as your best seams in
the team it's
it's definitely all going in that right
direction
um to be part of it and it's a cool
atmosphere
to be part of a massive
massive team with that one common goal
of retaining the cup or
or in the first cases of getting the cup
back to new zealand
and then the history behind the cup is
insane as well yeah and then winning
that cup how did how does that feeling
compare
um
winning the olympic gold was
pretty special to me because that's what
i worked 12 years of my life yeah like i
did dedicated myself to rowan yeah so
that was pretty surreal and really
special for me
but then to win the america's cup
and
to go on tour with her afterwards and
see
the passion
from not only the little kids but
like the middle-aged men and then the
old ladies and
everyone remembers peter blake and and
defend like black magic and
everyone remembers those days
and how great it was in like 95 when the
cup first came to new zealand and
that nostalgia
for new zealand is really special and
yeah it just brings all new meaning to
to the event and the cup and the history
behind it so
yeah the americas cup is just an epic
epic thing to win and yeah it's
completely satisfying when you got to
bring it home yeah um
we knew we had a smaller budget than the
other teams and we were it was the whole
new zealand at like the whole new
zealand it was the kiwi way really like
low budget small team
like
odds stacked against us and then we
dominate on a world stage it's
it's yeah it's pretty special so cool
and then what are the celebrations like
after america's cup
big team like that geez i'd imagine it
would be full-on it was messy
the night we won
anyone that was a kiwi or was related to
a kiwi was in that tent with us in
like
everyone was just drinking we were doing
bombs off the wall like
how key we could it be like
everyone was just fully clothed jumping
into the water
and then just drinking all night like it
was literally the like hundred best new
zealand beer drinking songs until three
in the morning
and everyone was just
losing their voices and and it was it
was a strange moment oh that's so good
yeah it was a good party and i remember
coming back to the base in the morning
after the big party and
of all people that were there was trevor
mallard the speaker of the house
was in shorts
and a t-shirt cleaning up in the tent
and we're like mate what do you have to
do
it's just helping out it was it was a
strange feeling
it was just a strange atmosphere but
man it was cool so got it and the same
when when you went in new zealand um
yeah definitely it was
it was almost just like not
disappointing but like
knowing that we were in
the midst of covert and everyone was a
bit suspect about celebrating but
it kind of
the party was short but when it was
happening man it was cool like when we
we run it
and you're out on the water and you have
that flotilla of thousands of boats and
everyone's trying to get closer to the
yacht and yeah um
i'm pretty sure i saw tamaedi on a jet
ski with the maori flag and like
it was just
there was
so many random things happening
and then to try and get the boat back on
the foils and get it back into the bait
like back into the the dock
to be greeted by crowds of people the
ship's horns were blasting
as we were coming back in there were
thousands of boats trying to keep up
with us and
and people just
absolutely ruining themselves on the
person on the boat they're like
and then you get back to the crowd like
you give back to the wharf and the wharf
is packed like there are people
everywhere yeah i
yeah i've definitely never experienced
something that that cool and that
special
um
yeah some kiwis love to hate the
america's cup but when you see it out
like that and you see everyone that was
there
and even talking to random people now
like one of my crewmates that i've just
met down here in town
was up there the day we won and and how
special it was to them
and
yeah it was it's a strange thing it
wasn't just aucklanders there were
people from all over new zealand and all
over the country
they're celebrating with us and
yeah it's
it's a surreal thing especially in new
zealanders yeah i you definitely can't
put words to it yes so cool and so cool
you've got to experience all of those
successes but then like like what
happened in the rowing you're straight
back to reality i mean you've won the
america's cup
and then yeah you're done like yeah like
you said you you become old news pretty
quick yeah yeah it is a strange thing
but
i guess for me this time it was pretty
cool um
i started this last campaign with no
children and
ended this campaign with two little
girls so yeah for me just to be able to
to go home and spend time with them
and and knowing we didn't have to go
back to work or go to another training
that was it was really cool to me
um
yeah it was definitely special to be
able to spend more time with them and be
i guess there's nothing cooler than
being your own child's
like idol yeah and seeing how cool it is
how much they love it and how much they
love having you around and things like
that so
yeah it was really really yeah real
special um
and pretty much after that we just got a
camper and went on a road trip
so
although we didn't get the good parties
it was just effort to be traveling
around new zealand and just having a
good time
and really
yeah seeing new zealand for what it is
so cool and then are you back in back in
the fire service now yeah so
yeah big for my job back and
um no they've been really good so every
time i
i get this opportunity with team new
zealand they
they give me unpaid leave and i get to
go off and
reproduce represent new zealand so
um when i come back i i get slaughtered
back into the cruise and
and kind of
get back into their lifestyle but for me
i guess the fire service is that same
kind of atmosphere you're
you're with a good group of people that
are all kind of striving to be the best
at what they're doing and yeah
there's always a good banter and we're
always trying to solve new zealand's pro
problems around the
coffee table in the morning
yeah
just [ __ ] yarns and lots of banter and
just yeah it's it's like being in a
sports team again and that's really cool
i definitely enjoy that kind of
atmosphere
um
and i think i've never been built to sit
behind a desk or do
a real paperwork job so
um something that keeps me active and in
the community is always really cool for
me so is that the plans for you going
forward stick stay in the service and
when the next america's cup
uh campaign starts you'll be looking to
push for that um yeah pretty much i i'm
one of those people i just kind of go
with the flow like yeah um
for me
when i got told to like i was in their
bed that bad way after
getting dropped from the team and there
was a couple of lads that i've met from
the fire service
that pretty much came up to me one day
and they were like look mate you're
you're in a bad way why don't you join
the fire service it's a really good
atmosphere i think you'll really enjoy
it and i was like yeah swedish
um
so it was kind of like my rowing career
i got told by the head boy to start
as far as it was i got told by a bunch
of guys to start like i've never
as much as i've thought i've had a plan
i've never had a plan and i just kind of
roll with
roll with it um
yeah i think in
what was it 2000
might have been 2019 i randomly got
asked to join the new zealand bobsled
team oh it's true
what happened there turned it down or
nana i flew over to canada and did a did
a stint yeah um we did the american
the it was called the americas cup for
for bobsledding over in calgary yeah a
north american cup sorry
um so flew over meet up with um
a guy called nick corbin and a guy
called um
i can't think it was named the pilot
but yeah meet up with this this group
and
like literally no budget had bought this
slid off
one of the canadian teams and it was one
of their old training sleeves
we literally had no money and no clue
what we were doing and we just turned up
and
and gave it a nudge
and we weren't even going there bad we i
think we were in the top seven
in this um
this event
really we just had
and
no one ever tells you i'm bob sitting
that even if you're upside down you only
go a few seconds slower
so no matter whether you start
upside up the right way or you're upside
down you'll still cross the finish line
wow so
you start start the rest and you can
flip completely upside down and you will
still cross the finish line
but just a few seconds slower
um and it it hurts it's it's not pretty
i think we crashed on the seventh corner
of 16
and you're still pulling like
three or four g's upside down getting
crushed against the ice
any major injuries from that or is it
just
[ __ ] scary uh
i think i got a bit of
like burns on my shoulders yeah no one
ever tells you that ice burns as well
the friction
when you're upside down going at 100k an
hour
getting pushed against the ice
really hurts so
as much as i enjoyed that my wife who
was heavily pregnant at the time decided
i wasn't doing that sport anymore
and i couldn't really disagree it
that's so cool you've just gone over
there given it a crack so you'd never
done it before you knew nothing really
about it or you must have known
something to be
half decent yeah
i literally i literally got sent because
simon van gaal having got asked to go
and he couldn't go because he was
getting married
so i was like
i'm on leave why not so
oh that is good stuff but you've done it
all
absolutely
mate what what a journey geez that's
some good stuff in there and real
interesting insight into um
life as a rower especially how you got
um
how it all ended mate there's crazy
stories there but as always we've gone
to our instagram for some questions
fair few have come through for you
the lad that you are uh first question
what's your favorite sport to watch
favorite sports watch um
at the moment i'm getting into the
formula one
um would you give it a go i'd love to
get a nicara i always saw myself as a
car driver but i'm always too
big nowhere near skilled enough um to do
that but
yeah quite enjoy the motorsport um
you can't can't not watch the rugby
really yeah getting behind the all
blacks
um
yeah but really anything olympics
anytime the olympics come on
doesn't really matter what sport it is i
just get into it
um
yeah it's just cool watching it
gives you all those same kind of feels
when you
see someone succeeding and winning and
yeah it gives you that nostalgia and
that reminder that what you've done is
pretty cool so
right they said you're too too small for
rowing but that didn't stop you maybe
you could give formula one a go
no way i don't think i'm rich enough to
ever get into those sets
it's true
okay uh next question what what's your
earliest grinding memory uh earliest
grinding memory i guess
um
when i first turned up to team new
zealand
and glen ashby was showing me around the
german
um it was back in the old team new
zealand base where the
the park hired us now um
just walking into that shed and you
always kind of think when you look at
team new zealand that it's a real slick
operation and they must have lots of
money and
all the gear must be state of the art
but then
walking into the team new zealand [ __ ]
and it's just a bunch of random machines
and
just bits and pieces everywhere
it's like literally walking into
someone's garage with all the all the
different equipment that they've bought
off trade me
just kind of realizing that like it's
just the true kiwi way like
as much as the team looks like it's
built on money
the money is all spent on the
development of the boat and
and the really important things
and everything else is just makeshift
and
kind of do the best we can
crazy yeah
the reality it was a pretty special
moment just realizing how
how kiwi the team was yeah and it wasn't
some big enterprise that i thought it
was it was just
a bunch of lads and girls doing the best
they can to build this
extreme boat crazy good insight okay
next question is from a good man called
jared uh how did you develop the sprint
of doom
um
it wasn't definitely by necessity we
didn't really have a choice
um
we were always trailing everyone else
all we had to do was do our best and
just kind of mongrel it to the finish
line so
um i guess it kind of developed in 2010
we were i think we were in third place
or fourth place coming into the finish
and we were coming to the finish line
and
the crowd was just so
massive
um on lake carapara and we just got
amped up
and just started pushing harder and
harder and just kept it going right to
the end and
it kind of just developed from there and
we
kind of got to a point where we realized
in the last 500
no matter how screwed we were we we
could always finish on a high so
it was just knowing that it was only 500
meters to go so
you could always finish
you what did someone say you pass out
you black out before you die so
the motto you've lived your life by
yeah yeah
i guess that was your fourth split the
fastest or
were they all pretty similar do you just
it just looked the fastest i think
to be fair we were actually
like our olympic race our splits were
pretty much the same the whole way
through like they were maybe a second
and a half
faster at the end but
everyone else was just getting slower
because they were buggered
we were just holding on really yeah like
everyone had spent their energy at the
start of the race trying to keep away
from us and
yeah and we're paying for it at the end
crazy
interesting okay next question if you
could have bears with any other sports
team in the world who would it be i
don't know there's too many people
there'd be i guess it would be a whole
bunch of individual sports people
um
that you kind of get together from like
drivers to tennis stars to
to the rugby boys as well um yeah yeah
i've met a few of the rugby boys and
they're always good to have a few beers
with
it's always just good having banter with
people that
have common
ideas and
common experiences i guess
yeah
you can't really be
getting on the path with a bunch of good
kiwis
always good times were you at the you're
at the um tasmaco final last year were
you yeah oh i wasn't at the final
unfortunately because we were out on the
water yeah yeah i was i was in the in
the lead out for it i was with the boys
um when they played auckland
and they actually got thrashed so
i don't think i was the best luck for
them every time i came and had a chat
with them or
i talked to them they always seemed to
get baited and i was like man maybe i
just need to stay away because
every time after that they end up coming
through and winning the championships
oh good times okay next question any
tips for pushing yourself as far as you
do
um
i guess you just need to find a sport
that you're passionate about and when
you're passionate about something
then you can give it your all um
i think that was always the most
important thing if you don't enjoy what
you're doing you're never going to be
able to push yourself
into that dark space to to do your best
so
yeah find a sport you're passionate
about and just enjoy what you're doing
and know at the end of the day you can
always recover
yeah
you're gonna pass out before you die
yeah and definitely
definitely in a race where it's a start
and a finish line
the faster and harder you go and the
more you push yourself the quicker it's
done
that's how i always look at it
it hurts less if you go harder
oh good stuff okay last question uh best
piece of advice you've ever received um
i definitely
took it on board i guess when i was a
junior and i
i got
um
i got bulleted by this family and a guy
called mike rogers who who rode back in
the day
um
and the thing he said to me that really
stuck with me is
it's as simple as controlling the
controllables and
for me that
like without even explaining it it just
made sense to me
um
there's so much there's so many things
that can
inhibit what you're doing or change
what's happening or
or like
throw a spanner in the works whether it
be weather or another crew or
another team doing something different
to what you expected
but at the end of the day all you can do
is what you can do and if you control
the things that you you are in control
of
then that's that's all you can do so um
yeah when you're in a race and some team
jumps out of the guns
forget about it if you're not doing your
best race then you're never going to be
the fastest anyway so why chase someone
when it can ruin your whole game plan
can i really have to stick to what
you're doing and believe in what you're
doing
and believe in all the training that
you've done
mate that is powerful stuff one of the
best pieces of advices we've had on the
podcast today wow we
love that
but anyway mate really appreciate you
coming on the podcast because that has
been an absolute unreal yarn unreal
insight into not only rowing but uh team
new zealand and the americas cup and
even even bobsled jesus had no idea
about that one but yeah right it's
awesome to uh hear a little bit more
about your mindset as well it's
incredible to hear how hard you push
yourself and mate really appreciate you
coming on the podcast and all the best
for the future good luck with the fire
service and your next stint with team
new zealand mate you're an absolute lad
so appreciate you coming on the podcast
thanks for having me you're a legend